Speaker 1: Welcome, everybody. So things in the
Russian invasion of Ukraine have not gotten any
better over the weekend, and I'm going to tell you
what's been taking place and talk about what might
be the most likely path towards de-escalation
given the personalities involved, particularly
the personality of Vladimir Putin and given what
we have seen so far. But in order to have the
conversation about how we might get out of this,
we have to understand how escalated things have
gotten and how committed to some degree Vladimir
Putin is about pushing forward and a major
sort of. I hesitate to use the term Red Line
because Red Line has had so many particular
meanings in foreign policy over the last 15 years
in the United States. But some kind of Rubicon has
been crossed over the weekend, with the start of
Russian attacks on Ukrainian nuclear power plants
and the concerns over an explosive disaster
proverbially and literally have now become a
significant part of the discussion as to what's
taking place. There's an Associated Press report
attack on Ukrainian nuclear plant triggers,
worldwide alarm and why would it not?
News from Kiev. Russian troops Friday seized the
biggest nuclear power plant in Europe after a
middle of the night attack that set it on fire and
briefly raised worldwide fears of a catastrophe in
the most chilling turn yet in Moscow's invasion
of Ukraine. Firefighters put out the blaze. No
radiation was released. Russian forces pressed on
with their week old offensive on multiple fronts,
although they did not appear to gain significant
ground in fighting Friday. The number of refugees
fleeing the country eclipsed 1.2 million.
One of the realities that we have to sort of
accept at this point is that this, you know,
pyrrhic victory may be too far, but the way in
which Ukraine is now reacting to the attacks. If
the invasion is ultimately going to be successful
for Vladimir Putin, and of course, I hope that
it's not, and I still believe that there's a
good possibility that it's not. Putin is going
to succeed in taking some extraordinarily lam
damaged territory. And what I mean by that is when
you consider the destruction to infrastructure
that the Russian troops seem totally willing
to make when it comes to nuclear power plants,
roads, important government buildings, et
cetera. And when you consider the refugee
exodus from the country and the further damaging
effect that that's going to have, if there aren't
people to take care of things, then it's going
to get even worse. There is a Putin who seems
determined to have a quote victory, no matter how
disastrous the victory is in terms of damage to
Russian troops in the Russian economy and to what
he's trying to steal Ukraine in and of itself.
And the nuclear power plant is just sort of like
the epitome of that because consider the damage
you could do by by going after that. Another
report Russian forces fire rockets at building
in Kharkiv that houses a nuclear reactor. This is
extraordinarily dangerous stuff, and I know some
will say, Well, David, it's not that dangerous. I
mean, these it's still probably going to be fine.
Yes. When you deliberately target these
types of facilities, you're willing to accept
serious and significant destruction, this article
reads. Ukraine's National Security Service
have claimed that Russian forces are firing
rockets at a physics institute in Kharkiv,
which contains nuclear material and a reactor.
Footage shows the purportedly shows the moment a
missile hits the Kharkiv Institute of Physics and
Technology, which houses the reactor. No immediate
reports of damage to the nuclear materials inside.
So one very important question now becomes What
is the off ramp if we let's concede a situation
where Putin is unable to take Ukraine successfully
in a short period of time? Imagine,
given the size of the Russian forces
and the seeming determination of, for example, Joe
Biden not to send troops in which I support. To be
clear, given all of that, it's not unlikely that
if this did last at this scale months or longer,
that at some point Russia would quote win
Ukraine in the sense of stealing it. But
it's not coming easily, and we're
going to talk about that more.
And given that what sort of circumstances
would be the most likely to get Putin to say,
I'm going to back off now? Well, the first and
the most important thing is Putin will back. Off
seemingly if he's dead or if he has some face
saving way of backing off, given that an attempted
assassination does not appear to be the policy
of any country that's been asked about it so far,
and we will get to that because there was a big
story on that over the weekend. How do you create
an off ramp for Putin, where he can sort of save
face? The best kind of average of everything that
we know going on would be? You have to make it as
difficult as possible for Russia to make progress
while making it as economically damaging as
possible. Does that have unintended consequences
of hurting the Russian people? Of course it does.
What is already happening? What's already been
done in terms of sanctions hurts Russian people
as well. Stories of, I mean, just anecdotally,
even just Russians outside of the country unable
to to use debit cards. I mean, at the micro level,
it's hurting Russians and at the macro
level, it's going to do significant damage
as well. Energy prices, all these different
things. But it seems as though what you.
Short of short of sending troops in to Ukraine
and starting to fight a ground war of sorts,
you need to continue sending support to Ukrainian
troops and what are at this point significantly
volunteers as well allow them to slow the
progress of Russian troops as much as possible.
Make it I mean, it's crazy the terms we're
talking about. We're talking about lives here.
Make it as deadly as possible for Putin to
continue pushing hurt the economy as much as
possible and pressure Putin to get some kind of
incentive to take an off ramp and then give him
some way to do it while saving face. Now what
will that mean? Does that mean you've got to
give them some land? I don't know. And this
is where diplomacy would presumably take over,
but that seems to be the path sort of
short of really waging a war in Ukraine,
which right now it's not really a war is an
invasion that Ukrainians are doing what they can
to repel understand that this isn't a war came up
because of aggressive behavior from both sides. No
Russia invaded Ukraine. That's what started this.
There has to be some path. That will suit Putin's
personality, and I don't know what that is,
but this isn't stopping Putin from trying to
knock out the president of Ukraine Zelensky,
and that's what I want to talk about next